[Musik]
jacky im süden des großen kaukasus
in dieser alten karawanserei scheint die
zeit still gestanden zu sein
[Musik]
in den alten gemäuern schlummern
tausende von geschichten aus der großen
zeit der seidenstraße
[Musik]
wir sind zuletzt von der türkischen
hauptstadt tiflis zur
aserbaidschanischen grenze gefahren und
haben nun die stadt stetig erreicht die
stadt hat wenig von ihrem orientalischen
charme eingebüßt
entlang der außenmauer der
karawansereien wird kunsthandwerk
verkauf das zentrum der stadt ist ein
wichtiges touristen ziel
[Musik]
außerhalb des stadtzentrums aber sind
die altlasten der untergegangenen
sowjetunion deutlich sichtbar
oktober industriegebäude zeitzeugen der
einstigen planwirtschaft
und überall im land ihre porträts
reliefs der staatspräsident und sein
verstorbener vater auch hier fordert
teppich und seidenfabrik von schild
[Musik]
früher hieß diese fabrik lehning
kombinat und beschäftigte 7000 menschen
jetzt nach der privatisierung des
betriebs sind es noch 900
mitarbeiterinnen sie fertigen baumwoll
und seiten teppich weniger als früher
dafür schönere vor allem traditionelle
gehen wir zu den webstühlen wir haben
kleinere auch ganz große auf den bis zu
20 quadratmeter große teppiche gefertigt
werden
dies ist ein teppich der trisa schule
wir werden 48 verschiedene farben
verwendet und unsere weberin müssen wir
über einen guten fahrt geschmack
verfügen ist das sei ja sagen wolle
ein teppich wie dieser wie viel zeit
braucht er sieben bis acht monate sich
sehr unterschiedlich hier wird besonders
dicht geworden und die motive sind sehr
verschieden
das ist sehr zeitaufwendig es braucht
auch viel herzblut aber unsere teppiche
werden deshalb auch sehr geschätzt hier
ist ein kontroll buch hier wird alles
notiert wie viele leute an diesem
teppich arbeiten wann die arbeit
begonnen wurde
von wem der wollen seiden anteil und
schließlich nach welcher zeitspanne der
teppich fertig wurde
weil die weberinnen im akkord arbeiten
leisten sich die meisten nur eine kurze
mittagspause
der arbeitsdruck ist größer als früheren
sozialistischen ländern kombinat
ich arbeite hier seit ich die schule
verlassen habe es läuft mir mit den
fingern immer schneller und besser und
wir frauen haben untereinander auch ein
gutes verhältnis
seit der privatisierung der fabrik
konzentriert man sich darauf hochwertige
teppiche und seidentücher nachbarn
tradition zu fertigen
qualität statt masse lautet jetzt die
devise
alles wird von hand gemacht dafür ist
unsere stadt auch berühmt und wir
möchten mit unserer arbeit dieses image
stützen
[Musik]
die wohl attraktivste sehenswürdigkeit
an diesem knotenpunkt der historischen
örtlichen seitenstraßen jackie ist der
kran pallas das unesco kulturerbe ist in
den letzten jahren sorgfältig
restauriert worden
wir werben tradition und geschichte
geradezu greifbar
[Musik]
wir fahren weiter richtung osten von
ferne grüßen die gipfel des großen
kaukasus
[Applaus]
doch keine reise ohne panne
umso baden.de dieseltreibstoff sozusagen
direkt auch die straße statt in den
motor
einziger trost wir wissen dass es auf
reisen auf die pannen sind im gedächtnis
am besten haften bleiben
[Musik]
unser auto muss zur reparatur und wir
wir müssen schauen wie die arbeit
bekommen
hilfe naht in form eines kleinbusses
einer maske wie diese fahrzeuge auf
russisch bezeichnet werden
pannen gehören hier zu unserem alltag
versucht mich diese frau zu
beschwichtigen
und den kaffee die landschaft ist
hier ist endstation ich warte bei einem
kleinen straßenmarkt auf das retten der
ersatzfahrzeug
dem duft des frischen fladenbrot es mag
ich nicht widerstehen
die brot verkäuferin erklärt mir dass
sie und die leute hier vertriebene aus
monika wachsen einem weiteren
konfliktherd im kaukasus leben sie vom
brotverkauf mehr schlecht als recht
dieses laura schmeckt wunderbar wir
frauen hier button alle brot unsere
männer hüten die schafe und ziegen oder
arbeiten auf dem feld haben sie kinder
ja wir sind zu viert ich bin verheiratet
und habe eine tochter und einen sohn
das brot schmeckt ausgezeichnet aber das
schicksal der vertriebenen macht mich
betroffen
die vertriebenen sind wir noch sehen
werden ein spielball der politik
wirklich helfen will ihnen hier niemand
und der brotverkauf beschert ihnen nur
einen kleinen zustupf
mit einem ersatzfahrzeug geht's weiter
[Musik]
dann steht die fahren wie er von den
ausläufern des großen kaukasus quer
durch die ebene zum rand des kleinen
kaukasus nach nafta lahm
wir sind mitten im erdölland
aserbaidschan da wo beim städtchen
afghan ein öl mit wundersame wirkung
gefördert wird um acht uhr morgens geht
es los
hier badet man nicht etwa in duft
essenzen oder gar in schokolade sondern
in reinen erdöl- höchstens zehn minuten
darf ludmilla das bad genießen
die lehrerin aus russland ist zum
zweiten mal hier zu kur für 26 tage
[Musik]
chefärztin mutter kümmert sich seit 32
jahren um die patienten
ludmilla leidet an einer schweren
hüftoperation sagt sie würde es hier
viel schlechter gehen
[Musik]
das nervt öle ist für die industrie zu
schwer und unbrauchbar zu heilzwecken
kommt es so wie es aus dem boden quält
in tanks wird auf 38 grad erhitzt und
fließt dann direkt in die badewanne
seit fast 80 jahren kommen gäste aus der
ehemaligen sowjetunion zum kurort mit
dem magischen klang 1987 badet denn hier
75.000 menschen im erdöl gegen rheuma
arthritis und schuppenflechte die
chefärztin ist stolz auf die renovierte
gesundheitszentrum das medical center
mit elf ärzten und spezialisten sei das
beste ihn nach thailand dass nach dann
an öl hat einen einzigartigen x factor
etwas vergleichbares gibt es auf der
ganzen welt nicht man schätzt ist seit
urzeiten schon vor langer zeit als die
berühmte seidenstraße durch diese gegend
führte konnte man hier das nachbarland
die legende erzählt dass einst karawanen
reisende die wundersame heilkraft des
öls entdeckten
die händler beobachteten ein kamel das
von seinen haut geschwüren genoss
nachdem es in einer pfütze gebadet hatte
sie begonnen das wunder öl zu
exportieren
[Musik]
eine million gäste sollen bereits vom
magischen erdöl profitiert und die
bilder gut überstanden haben
langzeitstudien die dies belegen könnten
gibt es allerdings keine
[Musik]
er kommt bereits zum vierten mal aus der
umgebung von moskau hierher und ist
oberst in der russischen armee seinen
namen wieder uns nicht verraten
genau acht minuten dauert das erlebnis
des obersten im 38 grad warmen öl einmal
pro tag
[Musik]
als ich vor über 20 jahren dieser
krankheit die schuppenflechte bekam habe
ich alles versucht ich fuhr zur kur nach
israel
auch bei uns in russland gibt es
verschiedene salz sehen und ich war auch
am mittelmeer an vielen orten aber
nichts hat geholfen
nur genau hier in after land hat die kur
jeweils genutzt
das öl besteht zu 50 prozent aus nach
berlin einem kohlenwasserstoff der auch
als motten gift verwendet wird laut eu
bestimmungen gilt nach tallinn als
potenziell krebserregende substanz das
kümmert hier allerdings weder den
obersten noch sonst jemanden ganz im
gegenteil ich glaube dass nach thailand
zu einem kurort von weltrang aufsteigt
und das hier schon bald vier länder ihre
sanatorien bauen werden
ich wünsche mir dass nachdem ein zweites
davos wird
von nachteil an ausfahren der mehr oder
weniger auf direktem weg zum kaspischen
meer in die aserbaidschanische
hauptstadt baku
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in aserbaidschan gibt nicht nur über
grund bohrtürme sondern auch fruchtbare
landwirtschaftsgebiet
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das zentrum von baku erreichen wir erst
dass es bereits dunkel ist
die drei sogar und flammen türme machen
deutlich dass vor allem das öl und das
gas den rechnungen land bestimmen
jedenfalls bin reicht um jene die vom
handel mit diesen rohstoffen profitieren
[Musik]
hier die halle die eigens für den
eurovision song contest richtet wurde
und quartiere mussten in den letzten
jahren modernen bürogebäuden teilchen
die einstigen altstadtbewohner von
bacchus enthält gesichtslos aussortiert
worden
nichts durfte der modernisierung der
stadt im wege stehen
im stadtverkehr sind fahren
luxuskarossen zu sehen
wir begeben uns ins herz der ölmarkt zur
staatlichen aserbaidschanischen firma so
kam
[Musik]
offiziell heißt es die ölvorräte des
landes sein eigentum des volkes
doch von diesem reichtum profitieren
längst nicht alle bürgerinnen und bürger
im land was sagt der vizepräsident von
ca zu diesem vorwurf der vor allem immer
wieder von entwicklungsorganisationen
haben wird er versucht zu relativieren
die dinge ändern sich nicht über nacht
baku das ist die glamouröse hauptstadt
aber wenn sie rausgehen in die dörfer
dann haben sie ein ganz anderes bild
wir können nicht sofort alle im land am
ganzen reichtum beteiligen
wir haben zudem die last der
vertriebenen aus karabach und 20 prozent
unseres territoriums sind besetzt
es wäre doch unsinnig gewesen die
entwicklung des landes von den dörfern
her voranzutreiben
wochenlang bemühten wir uns um eine
dreherlaubnis
jetzt ist es soweit wir verlassen backen
der staatliche energiekonzern sommer
öffnet uns sein reich cuffaro
stellvertretender ökologie direktor zog
begleitet uns unser ziel eine legendäre
erdölstadt weit draußen im kaspischen
meer
ihr anblick verschlägt uns den atem
nächster schritt die älteste und größte
ölförderanlage der welt ohne verbindung
zum festland
man nannte sie das industrielle
weltwunder ein netzwerk von über 300
kilometern stehen plattformen und einer
richtigen kleinen erdölstadt all das
erbaut auf stahl fehlen
heute ist ein echter schlager auch eine
zentrale für das ganze öl und gas der
umliegenden plattformen
von hier aus schneidet man es ans
festland und von dort mit der neuen
export pipeline bis nach europa auch in
die schweiz
das geschäft mit dem aserbaidschanischen
öl explodiert
[Musik]
hefter schlauri ist für mich und für
alle aserbaidschan ag in der ölbranche
tätig sind ein symbol der industrie
unseres landes ein symbol auch für die
zukunft aserbaidschan
wir sind sechs stunden von barcoo
entfernt auf der künstlichen insel
arbeiten ständig über 2000 menschen vor
allem männer in zwei wochen
schichtbetrieb trotz ölboom sind tiefe
einkommen und armut in aserbaidschan
nach wie vor verbreitet strompreis sich
glücklich wer auf ein echter schlag
einen job ergattert hatte die löhne hier
sind zwei bis dreimal höher als auf dem
festland
[Musik]
dafür ist alkohol strikt verboten wer
auch nur mit einer flasche bier erwischt
wird verliert auf der stelle seinen job
[Musik]
vor 60 jahren noch kämpften die männer
gegen stürme und wellen wie viele ihr
leben in echter star ii verloren haben
sagt uns niemand
das technische meisterwerk unter stalin
erbaut wurde zum stolz der ganzen
sowjetunion
1949 war es soweit nach einer
komplizierten bauphase die erste bohrung
im offenen meer
seither fließt hier das schwarze gold
[Musik]
doch es liegt noch vieles im argen
auch die lecken alten ölleitungen zeigt
sie uns nicht dafür präsentiert dass
seinen ganzen stolz sein ökologisches
vorzeigeprojekt in dieser anlage wird
erdöl aufbereitet und her wird und das
ist neu dass giftiger wasser gereinigt
dass bei diesem prozess entsteht
2009 haben wir diese hochmoderne anlage
errichtet sie reinigt das gift wasser
damit es nicht wie früher einfach
ungefiltert zurück ins kaspische meer
geleitet wird
für mich ist das eine große befriedigung
denn wenn wir es aufs jahr hochrechnen
so bewahren wir nun das kaspische meer
von millionen von kubikmetern von
hochgiftigem wasser
wir fahren zum herzen der riesen
plattform zur stadt auf stelzen wo über
2000 menschen wohnen und die labors
untergebracht sind
hier arbeitet seit 16 jahren die
chemikerin achimer achmedow war zusammen
mit ihrer kollegin analysiert sie
regelmäßig erdöl proben sie messen den
wasseranteil im rohöl
dieser bestimmt die qualität anhand der
proben wird klar in welcher
sedimentschicht man bohren muss meine
arbeit habe ich keine probleme aber die
lebenssituation ist schwierig rundherum
hat man ständig nur dass mir
man kann nirgendwo hin nach der arbeit
gehst du in den sport zahl ein wenig
spazieren dann kommst du nach hause und
schaust ein bisschen fernblick sie
schlafen und am morgen musst du wieder
früh zur arbeit
es ist eintönig 78 tage hintereinander
ein und dasselbe
in den alten zeiten was lustiger sagt
auch immer da wurde hier noch kräftig
gefeiert und getrunken
[Musik]
10 20 jahre 30 jahre sind viele schon
ein echter schlager im einsatz
[Musik]
dank obama zucker überall renoviert und
in die freizeit kultur investiert nach
hemer hat eine zehn stunden schicht
hinter sich so viel abwechslung wie in
ihrem wohnort bad gibt es nicht doch
immerhin ein breites sportangebot
sie wohnt wie alle in einem kleinen
feier zimmer neuerdings mit fernseher
und kühlschrank mit adela teilt sie das
abgeschottete leben mit durchaus eigenem
charme manchmal fragt man mich weshalb
aber das tun nicht am ufer du als
spezialistin würdest doch eine stelle
finden
aber ich will ehrlich gesagt nicht weg
von hier auch wenn die bedingungen
schwierig sind
unweit von echter schlag zeigt man uns
eine reihe von neuen kleineren
plattformen nach dem zusammenbruch der
sowjetunion schloss als arbeiten mit dem
westen den sogenannten jahrhundert
vertrag
2006 wurde die neue 1700 kilometer lange
öl export pipeline nach europa eröffnet
ein entscheidender schritt weg von
russland
neuerdings wird im kaspischen meer auch
immer mehr gas gefördert aus einer tiefe
von 3000 metern ca setzt auf weitere
riesige gasvorkommen und auf verkäufe
nach europa auch in die schweiz
[Musik]
nicht täuscht darüber hinweg der plan
des präsidenten kontrolliert das land
rücksichtslos drei wahlen freie medien
gibt es in aserbaidschan ich präsident
ali er fährt in der staatlichen
inszenierung wie einer gottheit einem
heilsbringer kohl ich trotzdem ganz
unterdrücken lassen sich die kritischen
stimmen nicht in baku gibt es eine
mutige blogszene in einer parkanlage
treffe ich sage generale und emil nach
einer kurzen unterredung begeben wir uns
gemeinsam in ein café ein bisschen
mulmig ist mir zwar zumutet auch die
blogger sind bereit sich bei ihrem namen
nennen und filmen zu lassen
es sei wichtig ein zeichen für offenheit
zu setzen
als junger mensch müsse man seine wahl
treffen zu gunsten des autokratischen
präsidenten regimes oder zugunsten einer
ersehnten freien demokratie
manchmal fühlte sie sich zwar gestört
aber wirklich gemaßregelt worden sein
wir wissen nicht wo die rote linie ist
die wir nicht überschreiten dürfen
manchmal kannst du sehr kritische dinge
sagen ohne bestrafung manchmal sagst du
etwas weniger kritisches und west sofort
verhaftet einmal wurde ich ins büro des
direktors zitiert als ich etwas
geschrieben hatte er liegt mir eine
erziehungs predigt diese art von druck
habe ich für meine kritischen artikeln
zu spüren bekommen
meine familie lebt in einem provinz
distrikt meine angehörigen mussten auf
den polizeiposten und wurden zu meiner
person befragt
auch auf diese art erlebe ich den druck
selbst wenn er in meinem fall bisher
keine schwerwiegenden konsequenzen hatte
kein pardon kennen die us amerikanischen
markt aber offenbar wenn es um eine
offenlegung der op sitzverhältnisse geht
[Musik]
eines der hauptthemen bei denen die
regierung sehr empfindlich reagiert ist
die frage was wem gehört in diesen tagen
bespricht das parlament einen
gesetzeszusatz der besagt dass es
strafbar sein soll die
besitzverhältnisse von firma netten
juristischen personen zu veröffentlichen
bis jetzt erhielten kritischen
journalisten das was man bei uns eine
traditionelle behandlungen wie
verprügeln verhaftung erpressung und so
weiter nun könnte es einen gesetzlichen
markt für solche journalisten geben
denken sie dass das internet im land
politische veränderungen anstoßen wird
es gibt leute die sich eine veränderung
wünschen und ich bin teil dieser gruppe
und wenn es leute gibt die so denken und
sich für einen wandel einsetzen ist ein
wandel unvermeidbar das inspiriert und
lässt hoffen
von einem arabischen frühling ist in
aserbaidschan allerdings kaum die rede
zu straffen
das regime alliance die zügel in der
hand
hier auf diesen baustellen in baku weist
nichts darauf hin dass das land den
krieg um das hauptsächlich von armeniern
bewohnte gebiet nagorny karabach etwa
einen sechstel seines ganzen kriteriums
verloren hat vor allem die afrikanischen
vertriebenen aus karabach fristen seit
bald zwei jahrzehnten ein trauriges
schicksal
von außen können wir diese fabrikhalle
nicht filmen die polizei ist
allgegenwärtig
dieses elend soll verborgen bleiben
[Musik]
hier leben seit über zehn jahren als er
bei gianna die aus dem konfliktgebiet
von berg karabach vertrieben wurden 100
200 genau weiß das niemand
der lärm der produktion im hinteren teil
der halb verlassenen fabrikhalle hört
tag und nacht nie auf
das ist rena effendi eine fotografin aus
baku sie kennt und begleitet diese
familie seit vier jahren mit der kamera
dank ihr können wir hier filmen man denn
trainer das soziale gewissen
aserbaidschans
der 14 jährige jared ist mehrfache
junioren kickbox meister von
aserbaidschan
die 35 jährige fotografin hat ihn immer
wieder porträtiert ihr fokus seit jahren
all jene die trotz des ölbooms in armut
leben
hier gibt es keine infrastruktur zum
leben kein gas nur eine improvisierte
wasserleitung mal gibt es strom mal
nicht im winter wird es schrecklich kalt
im sommer sehr heiß die betonblöcke
speichern die hitze der sonne die luft
die die menschen hier atmen ist
scheußlich voller zement stahl unter
ständiger lärm hier drinnen ist
beängstigend
das
[Musik]
amina die mutter von avid dem kickbox
meister sieht keinen ausweg
einzig aller spendet trost sagt sie und
sie hat es aufgegeben für eine bessere
bleibe zu kämpfen
[Musik]
niemand kümmert sich um uns wir haben
verschiedene anstellen aufgesucht aber
niemand hat sich das event hier
angeschaut haben sie sich beschwert wir
haben formulare ausgefüllt sie
versprechen uns zu helfen aber tun
nichts
[Musik]
es gibt zwar ein staatliches komitee für
die vertriebenen
doch für sie hier sorgt niemand
[Musik]
wie alle hier ist auch die familie von
schmidt nach dem bürgerkrieg aus berg
karabach nach baku geflohen
damals gab es eine million
aserbaidschanische vertriebene die
meisten bekamen inzwischen vom staat
eine bleibe sie aber gingen vergessen
davids vater ist arbeitslos wie viele
hier
auf unsere frage was david werden will
antwortet der junge polizist
immerhin die kinder gehen zur schule
ganz in der nähe
diese fotos hat rena bei ihrem letzten
besuch von schritt gemacht vor einigen
monaten
jedes mal wenn ich hier herkomme
versuche ich informationen über diesen
ort und dieser menschen zu verbreiten
wie über diesen jungen er ist vierfacher
kickbox champion von aserbaidschan 13
jahre alt und lebt hier
er verdient eine bessere chance im leben
[Musik]
mit ihren fotos wie lena aufrütteln
an diesem abend findet in der trendigen
altstadt von baku ihrer vernissage statt
sie zeigt bilder aus dem erdöl land wie
sie in aserbaidschan sonst nie zu sehen
sind
[Musik]
trainer arbeitete anfangs in baku als
dolmetscherin in der erdölbranche wandte
sich jedoch bald der
dokumentarfotografie zu jahre lang
dokumentierte sie den alltag und die
armut von einfachen landbewohnern
entlang der neuen öl pipeline
[Musik]
man überlegt dass der unglaubliche
ölreichtum idealerweise auch die
untersten bevölkerungsschichten
erreichen sollte aber das ist nicht so
das fand ich wirklich schockierend und
schäbig
von rena vernissage haben sie alle über
facebook internet und mund zu mund
propaganda erfahren
offiziell gab es keine hinweise auf die
ausstellung
ein wichtiger tag in einem land das fast
keine kritik erträgt es steht nicht gut
um die meinungsfreiheit bei uns sogar
meine fotobücher die im ausland
praktiziert wurden unterlagen der zensur
ich durfte sie nicht über die grenze
bringen rogers kam ins gefängnis und
ebenso jugendliche die ihr recht auf
friedliche versammlungen wahrnehmen
wollten
das ist alles ein schritt suchen wir
machen keinen fortschritt mehr
das finde ich eine schande
[Musik]
wenn man schon einer der anhöhe aus auf
das zentrum der stadt bakuba ist von den
problemen des landes wenig zu sehen
die altstadt ist schön herausgeputzt
viele ihrer einstigen bewohner mussten
und ticken und touristen jobs weichen
aber es ist bezaubernd doch diese kassen
zu flanieren
[Musik]
zurück im stadtpark der dem
aserbaidschanischen decor sabia der weg
mit ist heute findet hier unter offenem
himmel ein büchermarkt statt
eines der beliebtesten bücher im land
ist der roman ali und nino
die liebesgeschichte spielt in baku und
der russischen revolution spiegelt die
zerrissenheit eurasiens und jene
zwischen menschen christlichen und
muslimischen glaubens
der muslimische adlige ali verliebt sich
in die christliche kaufmannstochter nino
aus georgien ali fühlt sich im
aufgeklärten westen genauso unwohl wie
nino im traditionellen orient
vor der geplanten hochzeit wird nino von
oli's freund entführt
[Musik]
ali muss nach islamischem gesetz nicht
nur den nebenbuhler sondern auch seine
braut umbringen
alle tötet seinen freund und fliegt mit
nino die beiden heiraten allen
widerständen zum trotz
sie führen eine mischung aus
orientalischem und europäischem lieben
und bleiben in inniger liebe verbunden
[Musik]
bis alle im krieg gegen die bolschewiken
umkommt
nino hatten vor 100 jahren versucht die
religiösen schranken zu überwinden und
heute die schwierigkeiten scheinen etwas
kleiner geworden zu sein
vom schleier haben sich die asiatischen
frauen befreit
das ist in baku sogar in einem denkmal
verewigt vorbei sind die zeiten wo
offene haare nackte beine oder ein
tiefes dekolleté eine ungeheure
provokation waren
[Musik]
vieles hat sich verändert seit der
geschichte von ali und nino die tücken
der liebe aber sind die gleichen
auch zwischen menschen aus
unterschiedlichen welten
das ist unsere nino sie heißt natalie
eine christin aus weißrussland
und das ist unser ali turan moslem und
das serie moral ist so etwas wie ein
muslim leid er betet fünfmal am tag wenn
es mal weniger ist auch nicht schlimm
im letzten januar wagte natalia den
schritt nach baku aus liebe zu tuchel
einen job hat die studierte juristin
hier nicht das joggen ist einer der
wenigen fixpunkte im neuen leben in der
fremde
die leute schauen dich an weil ich keine
aserbaidschanische frau bin aber auch
wegen meinen haaren meinen kleidern und
ich trage ja keine kurzen kleidern
das wäre hier ein desaster auch für
total
[Gelächter]
lieber als über die schwierigkeiten
reden die beiden über ihre hochzeit im
februar ein märchen mit einer prinzessin
rund 130 gästen im hotel kempinski eine
mischung aus folklore disco und kitsch
alkohol gab es nicht sonst sei es ein
sehr westliches fest gewesen
mit der hochzeit musste es schnell gehen
zusammenleben ohne trauschein geht in
aserbaidschan heutzutage nicht auch auf
dem basar wo sie einmal pro woche und
immer neu zusammen einkaufen feld
natalia auf nur schwer gewöhnte sich
total an die blicke
die rollenverteilung ist klar er sagt wo
es lang geht er verhandelt er bezahlt
aber haben
trotz allem einen schleier den damals
ali für nino erwog bildet ural nie
verlangen
sie hat ein recht zu entscheiden
ich habe hier nie gesagt sie soll einen
schleier tragen sie ist frei und ich mag
diesen look das frisch verheiratete paar
wohnt in tour als elternhaus mit mutter
und bruder die annäherung mit der
eingeladenen verwandtschaft will
gepflegt sein
toral und seine cousins sind für den
kebab zuständig in der küche macht
natalia dollar die küche in
aserbaidschan immer noch das reich der
frauen den männern zu dienen
daran musste sie sich erst gewöhnen ich
möchte nicht dass es für total
unangenehm ist
denn seine verwandten kommen sehe mich
als seine frau für ihn ist es sehr
wichtig mich anderen zu zeigen
ich tue mein bestes sie kocht inzwischen
schon so gut wie eine asphärische frau
war merken wir keinen unterschied mehr
moral hat eine gute wahl getroffen
wir respektieren diese bahn lange tönte
es allerdings anders in der familie von
total 5 jahre so lange kennen sich die
beiden schon wollten sie ihn abbringen
von der heirat mit einer frau die weder
asiri noch muslimisch ist die total
übrigens im ausland kennen lernte
und jetzt wird ein hauch familien idylle
durch den bescheidenen innenhof doch das
ist noch nicht das ende dieser
geschichte im park wo sich die
romanfiguren ali und nido verliebten
verrät uns das paar was noch nicht mal
die familie weiß
wir sehen unsere zukunft im ausland wir
planen in die usa auszuwandern
wer weiß was passiert
die liebe ist unberechenbar sie hätte
nie daran gedacht dass sie hier in
aserbaidschan lebt ich hätte nie gedacht
dass ich mich in eine weißrussische frau
verlieben
wir freuen uns wir denken wir werden ein
gutes leben haben den usa und so endet
diese moderne liebesgeschichte nicht
tragisch sondern voller optimismus
[Musik]
mit dieser liebesgeschichte verlassen
wir den europäischen kontinent in
aserbaidschan lernt wir ein kulturell
reiches land kennen aber auch eines
verläuft widersprüche
in unserem nächsten folge reisen wir
durch zentralasien
wir sind dabei wenn auf einer
kasachischen farm kamele geschoren
werden wir lernen die neue und
topmoderne kasachische hauptstadt astana
kennen die mitten in die städte gebaut
wurde
[Musik]
und das totalitäre ob der talk minister
wo mein kollege mit jerry bock benötigt
wurde
die turkmenischen fernsehzuschauer mit
einem besonders regimefreundlichen
auftritt zu beglücken
[Musik]
[Applaus]